We're going to take
you straight to Washington,
where Merrick Garland is now speaking.
Let's listen.
Pursuant to Department of Justic
regulations governing such matte
in keeping with those regulation
I have today notified
the designated members of each H
of Congress of the appointment.
I'm joined today by John LaRoche
the U.S.
attorney for the Northern Distri
of Illinois.
Who conducted the initial invest
into the matter
that I will describe today
on the evening of November 4th.
2022.
The National Archives
Office of Inspector General
contacted a prosecutor
at the Department of Justice.
It informed him that the White H
had notified the Archives
that documents
bearing classification markings
were identified at the office
of the Penn
Biden Center
for Diplomacy and Global Engagem
located in Washington, D.C.,
That office was not authorized
for storage of classified docume
The prosecutor was also advised
that those documents had been se
in an archives facility
on November 9th,
the FBI
commenced an assessment
consistent with standard protoco
to understand
whether classified information
had been mishandled
in violation of federal law.
On November 14th, pursuant to Se
600 point
to be of the Special Counsel Reg
I assigned U.S.
Attorney Laws
to conduct an initial investigat
to inform my decision
whether to appoint a special cou
Mr.
LaRouche has served as the U.S.
Attorney in Chicago since 2017.
Before that,
he spent more than a decade
as an assistant U.S.
Attorney in that same office.
I selected him to conduct
the initial investigation
because I was confident
his experience would ensure
that it would be done
professionally and expeditiously
On December 20th,
President Biden's
personal counsel informed Mr.
LaRoche that additional document
bearing classification
markings were identified
in the garage of the president's
private residence
in Wilmington, Delaware.
President Biden's counsel inform
Lewis that those documents
were among other records
from the period
of the president's service
as vice president.
The FBI went to the location
and secured those documents.
On January 5th, 20, 23, Mr.
Walsh briefed me on the results
of his initial investigation
and advised me
that further investigation
by a special counsel was warrant
based on Mr.
Lucia's initial investigation.
I concluded that
under the Special Counsel regula
it was in the public interest to
special counsel
In the days since, while Mr.
LaRoche continued the investigat
the Department identified Mr.
her for appointment as special c
This morning, President Biden's
personal counsel called Mr.
LaRoche
and stated that an additional do
bearing classification markings
was identified at the President'
personal residence
in Wilmington, Delaware.
When I first contacted Mr.
LaRoche about this matter,
he said he could lead
the initial investigation
but would be unable
to accept any longer term assign
because he would be
leaving the department in early
for the private sector.
U.S.
Attorney LaRoche
and his team of prosecutors and
have conducted this initial inve
with professionalism and speed.
I am grateful to them, sir.
Earlier today
I saw
I signed an order appointing
Robert Herr, a
special counsel for the matter
I just described.
The document
authorizes him to investigate
whether any person or entity
violated the law in connection
with this matter.
The special counsel will not be
to the day
to day
supervision
of any official of the Departmen
but he must comply
with the regulations, procedures
and policies of the Department.
Mr.
Herr has a long and distinguishe
as a prosecutor
In 2003,
he joined the Department's
Criminal Division,
where he worked
on counterterrorism,
corporate fraud and appellate ma
from 2007 until 2014.
Mr. Herr served as an assistant
Attorney for the District of Mar
where he prosecuted
matters ranging from violent cri
to financial fraud.
In 2017.
Mr.
Hurry joined
the department
as the principal associate
deputy Attorney General in 2018.
He was nominated and confirmed t
as the U.S.
Attorney for the District of Mar
as U.S. Attorney.
He supervised
some of the department's more im
national security,
public corruption
and other high profile matters.
I will ensure that Mr.
Herr receives all the resources
to conduct his work
As I have said before,
I strongly believe
that the normal processes
of this department
can handle
all investigations with integrit
But under the regulations,
the extraordinary circumstances
require the appointment
of a special counsel for this ma
This appointment underscores
for the public
the Department's commitment
to both independence
and accountability
and particularly sensitive matte
and to making decisions
indisputably guided
only by the facts and the law.
I am confident that Mr.
Herr will carry out his responsi
in an evenhanded and urgent mann
and in accordance
with the highest traditions
of this department.
Thank you all.
Have you ever spoken to the Pres
about this investigation, sir?
And there
we just heard from the attorney
Yet another special prosecutor
has been announced
and appointed in regards
to classified
documents found in yet another
now current president's residenc
I want to bring in our panel.
Let's go to Andrew McCabe first
You know,
the special counsel Robert Herr.
He was appointed
by former President Trump.
It doesn't appear
that that was a coincidence.
As to why
the attorney general appointed h
He also went through
a list of dates
in terms of the sequence of even
And when the DOJ was notified ab
batch of documents, the initial
was found,
November 4th and November 14th,
he appointed John LaRouche
and December 20th.
Now, they were informed
that an additional batch of docu
were found.
Tell us what you make of
what we just heard from
the attorney general, specifical
with regards to Robert Herb
being named the special prosecut
Well, I
think the
selection of Rob
Herr is a logical and sound one,
as you can see
from the brief resume
that the attorney general laid o
Mr.
Herr is a essentially
was a career Department of Justi
prosecutor and attorney,
both served as an assistant U.S.
attorney in the District of Mary
which is,
of course, located in Baltimore,
and then spent some time
significantly at working at DOJ,
Maine and DOJ headquarters.
I worked with Rob
when he was appointed
as the principal assistant
deputy attorney general in 2017.
I always found him to be
well-informed, industrious,
hardworking guy.
And as you mentioned, Brianna,
I think it's not
insignificant that he was an app
from the Trump
administration, served
in the Trump administration.
As a very, very high level
official in the Department of Ju
So that goes to
maybe disarming
some of the political criticisms
that might come from the right
as a result of whatever results
come of this investigation.
And John Miller, I want to bring
John Lash was the U.S.
attorney in Illinois
who was first tapped to investig
and then the second batch
of classified documents that wer
We heard from the attorney gener
that he was briefed on January 5
by John
Lewis that he would support
further investigation
and the appointment
of a special prosecutor.
What do you make of this
in terms of where
this investigation stands?
Well,
I think the discussion
that we've all been having,
you know, over the last couple o
what is the difference in scope
between the Trump documents at M
a Lago,
which involved, you know,
possible obstruction
in and attempts
to hide them in denials
that they exist,
and a case
where the president's lawyers
were going through spaces,
looking for files
and found them immediately repor
But the special counsel regulati
does the matter merit investigat
which clearly this did,
which is why it was referred to
attorney in Chicago.
But also,
are there extraordinary circumst
And I think it was the judgment
of the attorney general
at this point
that rather than doing backflips
and tortured explanations about,
you know, it
not warning a special counsel
that the single extraordinary
circumstance was
it involved a sitting president
and those two things came togeth
The choice of the special
prosecutor in Rob her
is a particularly
well thought out one in that
you have a person who served
in the Department
of Justice
under Democratic administrations
at a very high level
as the principal associate
deputy attorney general
during the Trump administration,
who then really made a name for
as U.S.
attorney in Maryland,
prosecuting the former
mayor of Baltimore,
the former police
commissioner of Baltimore,
delegates in a state senator.
A lot of Democrats on corruption
But most
importantly,
if you're going to pinpoint this
he did two very significant
investigations into the NSA,
two employees, both of whom
carried large amounts
of classified documents out of t
One of them stored them
in his home, in his car.
Another had massive information
electronically.
So he is very adept at how to na
the care, handling, proper
handling of classified informati
and where the lines are between